بشكل لافت ومكثف اقتحم مئات المستوطنين
اليوم باحات المسجد الاقصى وسط حمايه من
القوات الاسرائيليه التي قيدت وصول
المصلين المسلمين الى المسجد نحو الف من
هؤلاء المستوطنين اقتحموا المسجد الاقصى
في اوسع اقتحام للمسجد بعدما اقتحمت
الشرطه المسجد واخرجت المعتكفين من داخله
بالقوه لتامين وصول المستوطنين الى المكان
هذا الاقتحام ياتي في ذروه توتر كبير في
المنطقه سببته الاقتحامات المتزايده ما
دعا الجيش الاسرائيلي لتمديد الاغلاق
المفرود على الضفه الغربيه ومعابر قطاع
غزه حتى منتصف ليل الاربعاء المقبل وفي
وقت تعيش فيه اسرائيل اوقاتا عصيبه
واحتمال اندلاع مواجهه متعدده الجبهات
اوسط الشرطه الاسرائيليه امس بعدم السماح
للمستوطنين باقتحام المسجد الاقصى خلال
العشر الاواخر من شهر رمضان في محاوله
لتجنب زياده التوتر وقدمت
التوصيه خلال مناقشات لقاده ورؤساء
الاجهزه الامنيه الاسرائيليه خشيه
احتكاكات قد تتحول الى مواجهات والى تصعيد
على نطاق اوسع وزير الامن القومي
الاسرائيلي تمر بن جزير رفض قبول توصيه
الشرطه الا انه عبر عن اعتقاده بان الجهات
الامنيه ستدعم توصيه الشرطه وستفرض منعا
على وصول اليهود للاقصى لمنع تدهور اكبر
للاوضاع في الجانب السياسي ارجع رئيس
المعارضه الاسرائيليه يا ايرلابي التوتر
الاوضاع بالمسجد الاقصى الى عدم مسؤوليه
حكومه بنيامين نتنياهو كما اتهم لبيد وزير
الامن القومي اتمر بن جير بمحاوله اشعال
الشرق الاوسط مضيفا ان ما يحدث حاليا هو
المتوقع عندما تكون المسؤوليه بيد اكثر
الرجال تطرفا في اسرائيل على حد قول لابيد
في اشاره الى بنكير نفسه
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات